[Music]
don't get involved
now London
what up fam sorry just putting a little
black buffalo in this kick the morning
off what is popping fam what a freaking
weekend man when stuff like this happens
it makes my job fun it when you get
these upsets it is a it is a fun gig
with this this fight world we got here
um
tell you right now dude how about Drake
dummy right they didn't call it dumbass
yeah I didn't caught dude that guy's
just taking else left and right man he's
just getting tore up online I mean
that's definitely not a fake person
that's making these bats for him because
he knows UFC so well dude can you
believe this stuff we got this one wrong
dude 500k dude I know he's definitely
using his real money that definitely
happened his bank account but this guy
man can you can you imagine he didn't
call freaking strickling dominating Izzy
what a dumb ass stay off our lane dude I
even heard he said minus 2000 one time
it's like dude get out of our get out of
our sport dummy
who got it right though who got this one
right there's a few don't get me wrong
there's a few with this the building got
right they're just the when everyone
goes this way they go that way hoping
they're right and then they're like see
I told you it's like yeah yeah no no you
got one out of two thousand dude way to
go man you know
um insane this is why it's the greatest
sport on Earth because a guy like Sean
Strickland can upset
and dominate a guy like uh Izzy arasanya
it is absolutely insane I think
um
what you're gonna see going around in
the world that we live in in this fight
space from other people that do shows
like this is we gotta you gotta be
careful saying that Izzy had an off
night is he this is he didn't show up is
he overlooked him is he's too active he
was tired are those things true Maybe
yeah maybe there's there's some them
some weight to that but what that does
when you do that you make these excuses
that strickling them beat the best Izzy
uh again is he had to take the fight or
short notice all this stuff you know the
UFC didn't want this fight what you're
doing is you're discrediting Sean
Strickland who put on I don't know top
five best Championship performances
we've ever seen Maybe
wow it might be crazy maybe the best
we've ever seen
um because anybody in this space as far
as MMA quote unquote experts whether
it's DC Joe Rogan
Bisping uh Luke Thomas
um I'm sure the MMA fighting boys
Ariel's team I don't I don't know
anybody in this space that I follow or
that I listen to called strickling
Strickland winning so
um that's what makes this such a massive
massive
um upset
it's almost hard to comprehend if you
would have told me
Monday morning
uh Sean Strickland is the middleweight
champion of the world I tell you all
would he catch him do you submit them no
no no no no he didn't get scratched he
didn't get touched and uh he dominated
legit dominated for five rounds but he
won one right some people gave him the
second
I didn't give him the second it's up for
that one's debatable I guess you could
have said Shawn sugar could have been
more active in that and you that's why
you give to Izzy but I would probably
lean towards Sean so it's a 5-0 shutout
for Sean Strickland
um I I'd be homeless if you if you said
you can put your house on the line for
Izzy beating Sean Strickland and you'll
get whatever your house is worth we'll
give you that back I'd be homeless right
now that's how confident I was is he was
going to beat him
you know things happen man and I think
and you know I'll take full uh uh
accountability here I think a lot of us
overlooked how good Sean Strickland is I
think we underestimate his uh
will to not only win and beat a guy like
Izzy but definitely isn't scared in any
facet of a guy like uh Izzy but also
Sean Strickland and Rogue mentioned this
on the fight companion most of us knew
this but he also at that level in in the
UFC they did all this testing on who
gets hit the less who gets hit the least
side who gets hit the least and who gets
hit the most and uh in in in training
camp and Sean Strickland was by far
number one
so my initial when I heard that I said
this on the the broadcast with Rogan I
said well who's he sparring
because if you're telling me it's like a
Seinfeld Kramer situation where he's
just beating up 10 year olds and I'm
like ah it doesn't count who's the next
guy in line and who's he trading with
but if even if you would have told me
Izzy's the least hit guy in training
camp Justin Gates is the leasate guy Max
hallway but it's not a a knock on Sean
Strickland my just follow-up questions
well who are they competing against
turns out Shawn Strickland's competing
against some pretty tough people and
that's not something to overlook the guy
doesn't get hit you know and that that
is just it's remarkable it is insane and
I think
you know
especially lately lately and even before
Sean Strickland has become a fan
favorite
um amongst the MMA community and even
outside of that but really the MMA
Community maybe not the the general
audience who sees his crazy outtakes
maybe they see one crazy thing that he
said and they judge him off that but I
think the reason why Sean Strickland's
having a success even when he went into
enemy territory even though Izzy's not
from Australia and people forget that
but even though he went into quote
unquote enemy territory and fought Izzy
in Australia where is these one you know
numerous times in is the most famous
person walking around Australia even
amongst the kangaroos he's more famous
than all of them but for Sean Strickland
he was getting chairs there as well huge
pop yeah he gets a huge pop and I I
there's a reason for this so he he gets
a huge pop over there
um you know I thought Izzy made some
miscalculations on when the the
china-colored shorts you know um some of
the stuff he said I think it runs people
the wrong way
um we'll get to Izzy and what I think
happened with him going to this but I
didn't want to start this show going
what happened to Izzy what's wrong with
Izzy that's unfair to Sean Strickland an
amazing Flawless Championship
performance that he had that's not fair
to do I'm sure you get that at a bunch
of other shows you're gonna watch right
now but what I want to focus on
initially is how freaking special of a
performance Sean Strickland had and back
to why Sean Strickland's becoming such a
big fan favorite and I don't even think
the UFC could have predicted this which
they should especially with their you
know the the captain of the ship over
there with Dana White because he's
similar to Sean Stricker than this is
we're living in a world where AI is
coming into everything
where uh people especially you know two
years ago it's getting a little less now
but still out there the the the cancel
culture is you know starting to
infiltrate in all sports right and being
authentic is going to be the biggest
thing that people have to realize
whether it's stand-up comedy podcasting
if you're in the NFL you're in the NBA
you're in the UFC even if it's gonna
upset people if you're authentic you're
going to win a ton of people over now
I'm not saying I agree with everything
Sean Strickland says what I agree with
is he's being his true self it's not a
gimmick it's not something that he wrote
down the night before thought of it's
not this horrible WWE promo that we got
when you know when Conor McGregor's
being authentic everyone that's that's
how you do it that's how you get Fame
and money and followers and they see
these weird kind of sheep promos that
you know that we knew the guys thought
about or wrote the night before with
Sean than the reason people are
gravitating towards Sean Strickland is
we live in a fake world we live in a
world where people are scared to say
their true feelings or true thoughts
whether you agree with it or not again I
don't agree with everything he says but
what I agree with is if you feel that
way speak your mind son do your thing
man now I don't want you to hurt anybody
you know I don't want you to be
anti-semitic or homophobic no I'm not
down with that stuff I don't think you
should lose your livelihood you know but
with Sean Strickland one of the reasons
why everybody
that sees this guy especially the
performance that he had and you go back
and you watch the clips of this insane
stuff that he says you realize okay
maybe I don't agree with it but at least
it's authentic in this fake ass world
and with AI coming in that currency man
of being authentic to who you are is
gonna go such a long way again whether
you agree with or not people go that's
him
you don't look at it and go oh this is a
Colby Covington situation or this is
that you know insert name who's faking
it no no no no no no no that's Sean
strickler man whether you like it or not
he is to quote the old school UFC motto
he's as real as it gets and I think the
UFC is going to do a good job
you know kind of feeding that and
hopefully they realize that this is an
angle that and it's refreshing and that
the public you know is is going to
gravitate towards us and you have a
massive star on your hands but you gotta
let them do Sean Strickland you got to
let him Strickland you can't put on the
you can't put on the blinders and say
you know I don't think Dana's gonna do
this I'm just saying maybe the rest of
the UFC Market team you know John your
champ now let's let's tone it down a
little bit we don't need that you got to
realize he's gonna say some outlandish
stuff you know he's gonna say some
outlandish stuff and you gotta you you
know you gotta let it Vibe with it now
the issue they're gonna have with Sean
Strickland becoming a massive star in
the face of the middleweight division is
they're owned by Disney and they have
these big you know companies working
with them and you know you're dealing
with corporate and you're dealing with
you know all sorts of bull crap left and
right in the current climate that we're
in
um even then you gotta the juice is
worth the square please yell at Sean
Strickland be authentic you do you just
do and I I really I I think that's why
Sean Strickland is a fan favorite for so
many Sean Strickland also represents a
lot of people that don't get a lot of
attention he represents you know he's
he's clearly uh a kid who grew up poor
and white you know and there's not a lot
of voices for that and for him to work
his tail off and become the freaking
middleweight champion of the UFC more
people can relate to that than they can
LeBron James
LeBron James is six nine whatever 260
pounds probably runs a 4-4 in the 40
jumps through the freaking building it's
tough to relate to that it's tough to
relate to Patrick Mahomes it's tough to
relate to uh an Otani you can relate to
Sean Strickland though if UFC smart
they're in the market mean today go okay
complete Ops or what are you we're used
to this is a wild boy here but in the
current time we're in it's authentic
it's refreshing there's a good way to
to use this to our advantage and they
can because you'll see you know they're
kind of uncanceable
you look at some of the things that have
happened in the UFC which I'm proud of
you know again I don't condone it what I
condone is they're not losing their
livelihood for saying certain things
you you got to give them some bit of a
leash especially you know just at this
UFC 290 uh was it 293 in Australia on
the undercard or even on the main card
guys got on them they dropped the out
the f word twice twice yeah and I'm not
talking about the the main f word no
homophobic slur yeah the homophobic slur
there
um
now
do I agree with no you know as people
said it before in this room of course
you know but it's but I'm just saying
it's like you know times have changed
and we got to give those guys a leash
you know meaning you gotta give him some
leeway because they just won the biggest
fight of their lives their their
emotional they're probably don't have
all their wits about them they're a
little concussed probably you know their
emotions are red and high and they just
get on there now should they lose their
jobs no that's what's great about the
UFC
every are you in the NFL they gave
password homes the mic after throwing
you know even though they lost this
weekend
um you know let's say they gave uh
DeShaun Watson who beat Cincinnati
Bengals the Bengals looked awful but
let's say they gave the mic to DeSean
Watson after winning that game against
the the Cincinnati Bengals he gets on
there dropped the f word oh he's so
screwed so screwed probably benched at
least a game maybe maybe half the season
probably was a few you know million
dollars in fines
for the UFC they you know they're more
uh
they're like things happen man you know
I don't think those guys are homophobic
you know yeah they shouldn't have said
that they messed up you know so I think
for for Sean Strickland there's in this
world of fakeness that we live in and
Instagram and you'll get someone social
media and you think that really is their
lives and it's 15 seconds of their day
and oh my God all and ai's coming in all
this fake stuff and these fake clips and
you'll see YouTube uh titles that say
you know Sean Strickland admits to you
know taking a fall against Izzy or
whatever the hell people are coming up
with these days to get clicks and click
on it just some trash video that's what
we've been consuming for so many years
now for Sean Strickland to come along
and go Love Me Or Hate Me man this is me
all right dude I dig it again don't
agree with everything he says everything
he tweets some of his stances on stuff
especially women but at least it's him
man you know now are you going to get
these big Marquee sponsors like is Izzy
and Jon Jones did probably not you know
they're just you know those Brands
probably aren't going to jump on board
all good but I think a lot more people
relate to Sean Strickland than they do a
lot of other professional athletes and
that's why he's getting so big and you
gotta run with it there's something
about when you hear him in interviews
you can tell like deep inside he's like
a good dude you can kind of tell yeah
everyone says that yeah everyone knows
him really well says yeah you know he's
that guy but he's also deep down like a
good person seems like he's a good heart
yeah a lot of stuff is when he was young
you know he just came up rough dude you
know his story is rough I think we just
put back up the food truck which Sean
Strickland thick boy right now you watch
that I I knew he grew up rough but this
dude grew up rough you know so
um he's a product of his environment
again don't agree with everything he
says but it's refreshing that he's not
selling out when so many people would
especially when they become Champion
when they're getting there you know and
the UFC is worried about this
I also think one of the things uh that
makes Sean Strickland such a fan
favorite too especially right now you
know he's popping especially after
beating Izzy but one of the things that
makes him a fan favorite too is the way
he got the title he was not supposed to
get this they were doing it it was gonna
be Yuri versus Alex Pierre they tried
that can they get it together and time
enough it's gonna be Jon Jones versus
Sergey that that didn't happen they were
doing everything they could uh because
do policies couldn't fight they're like
what are we going to do that even though
it's sold out we need a big name and is
he was like I'll do it because he's like
dude we don't want Trump's freaking me
Champions this is an easy night don't
worry about it I'll take care of them
boy
boy was boy was uh is he wrong you know
everyone pretty much yeah yeah
and I think you know this Underdog Story
this crazy Underdog Story from a kid I
think he's from Covina is that right
he's from Covina
you had his Wikipedia up right there I
just typed it in there's nothing about
convenience it says fighting out of
Anaheim
oh he's from Anaheim
close enough
Strickland grew up in Corona oh so you
think Corona then yeah San Bernardino no
Corona yeah Corona yeah
oh
um Tatiana Suarez is from Covina that's
what you're saying yeah yeah I know it
started with a c Corona either way you
know the kid grew up you know poor white
family and for him to be the
middleweight champion of the world is
insane
insane so how do you get it done right
how do you get it done was it a matter
of is he having an off night maybe
something to that when we'll get to that
um but you can't discredit Sean
Strickland for fighting Izzy the way he
did at the distance he did and I think
one of the issues that Izzy had where
other guys
you know Izzy is a counter fighter so
when people get going oh Izzy's on his
back foot Izzy's backing up it's like
have you ever watched an Izzy Fight
Before It's very rare he's coming
forward he waits for you to make a make
a mistake and then capitalize on it like
the Alex Pierre fight you know other
fights that he's had before that's what
he does you get the Kelvin gaslin fight
where it's Toe to Toe you know but he
took a lot of damage in that so he
changed his you know approach to the
game but outside that he's usually
pretty calm calculating he is on his
back foot so that didn't surprise me you
know and Sean Strickland's the pressure
fighter so that's the way that dance was
going to go Sean strickson's gonna lead
that dance what surprised me which I
think surprised Izzy's Camp what they
overlooked is Sean Strickland a yes A
pressure volume fighter
was at the perfect distance where the
the leg kicks of Izzy wasn't a factor in
any facet so you took away that major
tool for Missy the kicks were not
Landing when they did he was checking
them really it was even and I meant to
say it on the fight crane because Rowan
kept saying oh it hurts you more when
you're throwing a kick and the guy
checks it Sean shrika he did check a few
but he was just letting it go with it he
was letting it go with he was the way he
rolled the punch he was rolling with the
leg kick with his leg you know because
he I don't think he has a quad for God's
sakes so that's the other thing that has
one one quad and it's the middleweight
champion of the world but so the way he
was able to uh make Izzy's Light cakes
just kind of a non-factor we've never
seen insane so that's one thing is he
had to deal with the second thing is he
had to deal with is like an Alex pierra
like a Pollo Costa like a Marvin
Victoria Robert Whitaker especially when
he got knocked out those guys would be
the aggress sir and they were punching
first they were trying to knock Izzy out
first Izzy would counter and knock them
out so he got away with that for a long
time would set up traps with faints
because he's a counter puncher he's a
counter Striker so he would faint you
faint to get you to throw a big shot he
could tell where that shot was come from
they capitalize on it knock you out or
land a big shot and and score points and
eventually get you out of there what
Sean Strickland did that was brilliant
was
while Sean Strickland was the aggressor
he was also a lot of times the counter
puncher
meaning he he would go and he'd wait for
Izzy to do something and then he'd
capitalize not even is he throwing a big
shot or throwing a jab but he he would
capitalize on all that and Izzy couldn't
get his awkward timing down
because you gotta think out of all the
training Partners is he has he doesn't
have anybody like Sean Strickland you
know that awkward style that weird
Philly shell with no leg kicks and I
think what else Shawn Strickland did uh
well
is I think kids who are wanting to fight
or even if you're in the UFC especially
in the division meat and potatoes wins
the meat and potatoes wins the guy who
throws a jab and a right hand uh 10 000
times I'm more scared of of the guy
who's throwing a million things a
thousand times
um so I think Sean Strickland went off a
jab and a right straight right
and great great footwork and distance
control and just a pace that would melt
most men and he he's a guy where is he
was he was in trouble early on in that
first round when he when he wobbled him
you know that gave Sean Strickland a
confidence knows he belongs which is a
terrible thing for Izzy which most guys
don't feel that way he's Alex Pierre
felt that way
um
and then obviously young which you lost
to other than that most guys when they
get in there with Izzy don't feel like
they they can get it done there's been a
few dude and I think for Sean Strickland
having success in that first round was a
big issue for Izzy and also is he's like
oh man I'm gonna fight here I mean he
never got it going after that maybe it's
because he's concuss who knows but
um Sean Strickland had a Flawless
Victory again I scored at 5-0 you want
to say four to one I can argue with you
but you sure as hell can't say three to
two
four to one cool five zero the way me
and Rogan uh Callan and Sam tripley
scored it but
um just an insane performance from uh
Sean Strickland absolutely insane
so what's next what's next for both
gentlemen Dana in the press conference
came out and said immediate rematch I
disagree with that I don't think that's
smart I think one of the reasons
um is the and we don't know here's the
thing Izzy hasn't come out he he skipped
the press conference he let his coach
Eugene speak for him which I would have
liked some answers from Izzy I know he
doesn't want to make excuses and take
anything away from Sean Strickland so
kudos to him but I would a lot I would
have liked some sort of insight on what
exactly was going on you know I would
like to hear from him if it's just
chancho because it's not fighterman I
looked off now this other thing you got
to remember when people go Izzy looked
off okay well he's fought very difficult
guys before you know he's had slow
starts before
did he look off because of the awkward
style of Sean Strickland there's
something to that again you can't just
say Izzy had a bad night and Strickland
had a great night you just can't so
going back to the rematch
I can argue both ways
I don't like the rematch for this reason
because one of the things I think
happened with Izzy and we're going to
find out more I'm sure in the the next
coming uh days here once Izzy speaks but
I think one of the issues is is how
active is he is as his champ
he's the most active champ I've ever
seen it's insane was this the 11th title
fight that what so
um
you gotta realize he's been champ since
2019 and he's fought one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten eleven
times since 2019. all championship
fights so being that active while it's
good and you're making money and you're
winning the majority of your fights
um and you you are staying active and
it's good to be active you don't want
these long layoffs but it's just damn
near impossible to do to fight at the
level he's at can you do it you know
when you're you know a guy who's running
you know seven to Fifteen maybe if
you're outside the top 15 it'd be tough
but when you're the number one guy in
town when you're the number one guy in
the world and you're fighting the very
very best it's very tough to be that
active and win every fight it's just
it's that the training camps heavy lies
the crown the training camps cutting
weight the emotions the mental space and
then also the other thing Izzy has going
for him which is one of the reasons is
he's so famous also one of the biggest
names not named Conor McGregor in the
UFC maybe the biggest not named Conor
McGregor is he engages with the trolls
he reads the comments he gives that
energy so I I just think again heavy
lies the ground when you champ
and you're required to sell the
pay-per-view that's one of your you know
jobs is to sell papers for the UFC
you're doing a hundred freaking
interviews that fight week it's
exhausting you know so I think it just
it's a lot of weight to carry to be that
active and I think it finally caught up
with them that finally caught up with
them I also think I I allude to this on
the fight campaign too I think we're
live by the time but I said one of the
ways Sean Strickland can win and really
the only way I thought he could win and
I was wrong so is Drake but I think one
of the only ways Sean stroker can win is
is he overlooks him and wrongness no not
no chance he would never do that
and I don't think he purposely meant to
do it I think he thought looking at Sean
Strickland's previous fights and seeing
how he did against Jared Cannon air and
see how he did against Alex Pierre
especially Alex he got I'm gonna mop the
floor with this dude man no I think it's
again he he didn't go on the fight going
this can be easy I think Matt I'm so
much better than this guy I think he had
a great training camp I still think he
trained a championship level I just
think subconsciously he thought it was
gonna be an easy night in the office and
again being so active there was no
reason for Izzy to take this fight if
this fight's not in Australia is he not
fighting Sean Strickland Sean
Strickland's gonna have a fight at least
once or twice before he even gets the
title shot you don't beat Maga Madoff
and uh imamov and get a title shot
coming off two losses that's not
happening
it's just not so Izzy's the one that
made this happen the UFC was trying
anything they could do to not make Izzy
for Strickland happen for this exact
reason and Izzy sold Dan in the UFC
going I'm gonna mop the floor with this
guy and boy was the UFC off and boy was
his yuff Strickland was like sign me up
sign me up man so
I again back to Izzy one of the reasons
I don't want to see the rematch is
because this isn't a uh a Matt Sarah GSP
situation where it's this
you know Hail Mary knocks him out in the
first round
and you're like oh God GSP what are you
doing man let's go here what are you
doing then they rematching beats the
brakes off of them that's not this was a
a a a a a full five round fight
for 25 minutes and the guy got hit 22
times in the face
that's insane that's a complete
domination across the board when it's
dominant like this
it's tough to ask for a rematch
and and the other
con that Izzy has working against him is
he's also lost three what out of his
last seven he's lost two of his last
three
so that that's where again huge Izzy fan
here but look at this black and white I
don't want to upset the Izzy people on
Izzy but look at this black and white
you go okay the guys lost two of those
last three
you know and then again this wasn't one
of those fluke situations whereas the
first round first 30 seconds Strickland
goes wild catches him and you're like ah
Come run that back dude you caught the
champ you lucky shot there's no lucky
shot here
there's there's nothing lucky about this
this was a complete dismantling for 25
minutes
so it's for me those are tough it's like
the the Julian Pena uh Amanda Nuna
situation
the first fight right you're like what
is going on with Amanda here right like
what the hell is this
they rematch complete domination all
right it's 1-1 I'm good if someone
dominates you
for whether it's a three round fight
five hour fight I'm all set man that was
not a mistake that wasn't just oh he had
enough night he had a good night when
you're dominated you know for 25 minutes
if you're dominated for 10 minutes okay
and then you get together the last 15
all good but when it just a complete
shutout I I don't like the rematches
I don't like who've been better if Izzy
got knocked out in the first mid second
of that fight to get in order to get the
rematch that being said
I also think Izzy needs a break I think
he's way too active at the fight at the
level he's fighting at I think he puts
too much emphasis on social media I
think he's too worried about what people
say I think he needs to step back
recuperate let the division do its thing
get some more contenders in there
because you've beat everybody get some
more contenders in there let Sean
Strickland get his shine let's say Sean
Strickland builds himself up even more
whoever they decide to throw him next
and then jump back in
slow down all good still one of the best
to ever do it and you you got to be
careful not to be a prisoner of the
moment I see a lot of people told you is
he's not that good told Jesus he's not
one of the greats you out of your
freaking mind despite you know maybe you
don't like the eye paints his
fingernails maybe you don't like the guy
where the China flag colors on his
shorts you know maybe you don't like the
way he does certain things maybe you
watched a fight it was boring whatever
to say is he's not one of the greatest
middleweights of all time you just
you're just dumb you're just dumb look
at his resume son Marvin vittori Brad
Tavares Derek Brunson Anderson Silva
Calvin gasum might be the greatest man
weight fight of all time Robert
Whittaker Joel Romero Paulo Costa
then goes up
to light heavyweight and fights Jan
block which lost but still tough to ask
at least he did it again Marvin Victoria
again your hardest beat a guy twice
Robert Whittaker again
Jared Cannon air who's a Savage loses
Alex Pierre oh my God he was 0-3 against
Alex comes back one of the greatest
knockouts of all time against Alex
appear who's twice the size of them they
lost Sean Strickland
so you're telling me
the guy who lost the
take out yawn that's 205 let's take that
out the only people to ever beat Izzy is
acts Pierre the world-class Striker
might be the best Striker the hardest
hitter pound for pound we've ever seen
the UFC
he lost to him once and redeemed himself
and then he lost to Sean Strickland on a
short notice fight
you're gonna discredit that you're a
prisoner of the moment you're just wrong
you're just wrong I think he's better
than Anderson Silva I have him over
Anderson Silva like oh my God it
remember instant that's hot so don't
argue with me
it's insane to take this away from Izzy
again when you guys got to be careful
because when you talk about how bad is
he is even though he's only lost two
fights ever at middleweight before this
one to ask Pierre who had his number
who's 2-0 going into that fight against
them
when you take away Izzy's body of work
one of the greatest resumes to ever
happen in the UFC one of the greatest
performers maybe the greatest Striker
we've ever seen him to see when you take
all that away and go he's not that good
again you're doing a disservice to Sean
Strickland Sean Strickland beat in his
prime
arguing the best middleweight of all
time you want those people if you're
Sean Strickland fan if you're an
oxpierre fan if you're a Robert Whitaker
fan you want Izzy to be one of the goats
of the middleweight division it makes
the guy that you like look better
your argument is stupid
it's Izzy man he's one of the most
active Champs we've ever seen at a high
level he's been the face of the UFC
especially since Connor's been you know
gone basically he's he's been the favor
he's been carrying all that weight this
entire time for a reason a good reason
so when you knock down the guy that
that just lost in your prison of the
moment you're doing a disservice to the
guy that beat him and that's Sean
Strickland Sean Strickland
just beat arguably the greatest
middleweight in his prime of all time it
wasn't a fluke
didn't catch him
Izzy wasn't sick
has he showed up his coach said he had a
great training camp Sean Strickland beat
that version it's not an older Anderson
Silva
some older you know an older Joel Romero
no no he beat Izzy who is ready to go in
his prime that's insane so when you
knock Gizzy and become a prisoner of the
moment he was never that good you
actually just got uh Sean Strickland
it's insane
so what do they do again here's my
argument for not having an immediate
rematch is he needs a break let the
division the the middleweight division
has been slow dude it's been held up for
a while and why is that
is it because as he's beat everybody
some most of the contenders he's beat
twice
why do you think they pushed duplicities
up so fast why do you think they pushed
out to Pierre up so fast
because he beat everybody he lapped
these dudes you think you'll run at the
same speed he lapped ya
he lapped you so yes he had to come up
with some narrative to push Alex Piera
who basically had the easiest run of Top
Shot of all time and that's not his
fault kudos to him and he's so skilled
but the UFC had to do that because
that's how freaking good is he was he
was laughing folks beating him twice
like you can't do the third time yeah
but Whitaker's one three in a row I know
but is he dominated him but Marvel
Victorious beat him twice
that's how good it is he is
so again I I I this division needed this
if this is a good thing guys even though
I'm a huge Izzy fan huge Sean Strickland
fan this is a good thing
this is a good thing for UFC business
it's a good thing for the middleweight
division that division's been
you know look at look at Jen has up
right now the rankings
you'll get lightweight you look at
welterweight you have middleweight there
you have light heavy weight there the
rest of them are popping Daddy
you got marketev at 55 you got Leon
Edwards fighting Kobe
Covington's out now middleweight it's
just been this constant Izzy train he's
beating all contenders beating them some
of them twice to pushing oxy Pierre had
to jump to light heavy weight just to
mix things up he's getting bored
a light heavyweight it's fun that that
belt's getting passed around like a you
know
you gotta be careful my words here
you know what I'm saying though so this
is a good thing so again that's one of
the reasons I don't want to immediate
rematch I think is he needs a break I
also think we need to focus and put some
energy into Sean Strickland he is that
guy he is that good he is authentic in
this fake world let's run with it
uh for duplicities you could do him next
I think one of the reasons they pushed
him again fresh meat for Izzy if Izzy
wasn't a champ if Strickland was
championed a year ago I don't think do
polices is in this conversation I think
they you know pushed him in the Robert
Whittaker fight he passed the test now
he's number one you could do Sean
Strickland do policies I heard
duplicities with the injuries not ready
to go yet Sean Strickland could fight
tonight
after dominating is he not getting hit
he could fight tonight show your Champ's
ready to go
here's my thinking
so we got to figure out the two places
where's he at with the injury when is he
ready to go do please see Sean
Strickland to sell pay-per-views I don't
know we'll see what Sean Strickland does
um Izzy sits back takes a little break
recoups re recalibates uh gets his
together
um the magnitude and the the the
implications of Paulo Costa and hamzat
is everything
the fight's going down in October right
Jen October 21st or 23rd in Dubai
yep October 21st followcast
depending where the police is at with
his injury and and again if Hamza
hamzat knows if the undefeated Hamza if
he goes out there and mops the floor
Paul Acosta I don't care if the police
is ready to go he's getting your next
title shot
even if two places goes whoa hold up
I'll be ready by November I'm ready by
December the new season go okay let's
see what hamzat does
hamzat's your next middleweight
Superstar that's what they're waiting on
but he has to pass the tough test of
Paulo Costa
the implications of Paulo Costa hamzat
just went up tenfold now that Izzy lost
now is he lost it goes up tenfold
and now if hamzat again mops the floor
with Palo Costa he's gonna be the guy
they push he's gonna be the next in line
he's the next face of the UFC
now if Paula Costa B Thomas art he's not
I don't think they push him the same way
not the same way they're waiting Hamza
they put a rocket
fuel pack on you know a while ago a
while ago especially when we're doing
the lockdowns and all that stuff they
put that jet pack on him he took off
with it and they had that layoff but
he's back right so
you know they try to give them the the
Nate Diaz fight they've been trying to
get have Hamza be the Superstar so now
Paul cost is here and there you go so I
I think uh the the wear of uh Hamza Polo
Costa will get the next shot if one of
them has a great night if it's a
decision a boring decision you get a lot
of wrestling you get a boring you know
three-round decision do please gets the
shot
but the next guy up
could easily be whoever shows up between
hamzat and Paul Acosta that's your decks
one in line if not yet duplicity's there
take my money for any of them do please
see Strickland that's a fun that's First
Team all awkward both of them
if it's Costa Hamza take my money
whichever one of them gets the job done
on October 21st take my money they have
Strickland cage side in Dubai
at that fight you have him and homslot
face off dude take my money
before again frizzy just lay low
recuperate recover you've done enough
dude you've carried the UFC on your back
for how long now so since 200 for four
years
for four years man you got to be tired
you gotta be sick of it it's all good
man you're doing the best ever do it
nothing be embarrassed about all good
but but you guys got don't be a prisoner
of the moment don't go ah Izzy's not
that good because then you're saying
Sean Strickland's not that good and if
you know Sean Strickland fan you want
him to beat the best version of Izzy but
we're gonna find a lot more in the next
coming few days here I assume on
Instagram or on his podcast Izzy has a
great podcast of what exactly was going
through the mind of one of the greatest
ever do it and what went wrong for him
no matter what no matter what he says
don't let that take away on how freaking
special Sean Strickland is
football's back though baby yeah
football is back oh my CU Buffs what's
up Prime Time Dion baby CSU good luck
this Saturday we're gonna beat him up by
100 dude we are popping dude the CU
Buffs are popping we're gonna beat the
brakes off of CSU the real test comes
the week after it's at Oregon one of the
toughest places to play in the nation
they're going at Oregon then after that
the Trojans USC is coming to Boulder
Colorado dude if we're ranked 18 right
now if we beat Oregon we're going
Sizzler then you got USC versus
undefeated cu come off an Oregon win
we'll probably ranked in the top 10 I
think USC's top four top five what I
mean you have Texas up for USC at five
then you have number 10 see you
undefeated with Prime Time Deion Sanders
Travis Hunter
little Dion Junior at quarterback what
but you can bet on the Buffs with my
friends at DraftKings you had an epic
week one in the NFL My Boy Aaron Rodgers
playing tonight against the Buffalo
Bills I think he's a minus two dog I
will take that all day until you're on
bent with my boys at DraftKings an
official sports betting partner of the
NFL new customers can bet five dollars
on football and get 200 instantly in
bonus bets nobody's missing on the
action this season all DraftKings
customers can take advantage of two new
offers every game day this September
Monday night football kicks off tonight
Jets bills bills are minus two dogs I'm
taking the Jets get in on the NFL week
two action with DraftKings Sportsbook
download the app right now use the code
shop show Schaub show to sign up new
customers and bet just five dollars and
take 200 instantly in bonus bets only on
DraftKings Sportsbook with the code shop
show the crown is yours DraftKings
I have to read that now don't I Jin
oh you want to be a podcaster huh this
is what you guys get to see live
gambling problem call 1-800 Gambler
visit www
dot one dot 1 800 gambler.net in New
York call
8778 Hope and wire text Hope NY
467-369 in Connecticut help is available
for problem gambling call
888-789-77 or visit
ccpg.org please play responsibly on
behalf of Boot Hill Casino Resort Kansas
21 older age varies by jurisdiction void
in Ontario
I think that's Canada sea Sports
book dot DraftKings dot slash football
terms for eligibility uh terms
responsible gaming resources bonus bets
expire seven days after issuance
eligibility just deposit restrictions
apply
DraftKings go Buffs promo code shop Show
Jesus yeah one more
yeah one more one more is it happy hippo
the best Kratom on the planet the only
crowd of my trust to put in this body
this freaking Temple only takes happy
hippo
this is my second Kratom energy shot of
the day this is the Cherry Pom-Pom I
think uh that stands for Pomegranate but
it's uh this is my favorite here they
have the high concentrated uh Kratom
shots from Happy Hippo they got the K
dips the Wintergreen they got the Razzle
Dazzle they got gummies they got powders
it's the only company I trust to put in
this body man I use it before all
stand-up shows before podcasting
probably work out uh Happy Hippos the
One-Stop shop for all your Kratom usage
go to happyhippo.com promo code is
thick23 that's thick with three C's you
get 20 off for Life off the k-dips the
Kratom energy shots my personal favorite
the highly concentrated shots the
gummies the powders however you want to
get your happy hippo we got you covered
go to happyhippo.com promo code is thick
23 for 20 for Life son let's get back to
the program chin all right
um
let's start off with this real quick the
other fight that we saw over the weekend
in The Green Room was uh bare knuckle
yeah
let me get it yeah for Doom versus JDS
young bare knuckle MMA and shout out to
the final kid Army for selling out all
the shows in Covina yeah we're watching
it that was a good time yeah that was a
great time me and Cal haven't been
together a hot second I'm in Spokane
September 21st to the 23rd you don't
have to bring it up I remember skank
Fest September 29th and 30th uh them in
Iowa Chicago so get your tickets at
thickboy.com but yeah we had uh the JDS
Fabricio verdum bare knuckle MMA fight
going on in the Green Room Covina
um this is my argument with bare
Knuckles so I know Rogan loves it and
him and Eddie used to argue with me how
UFC should be bare knuckle I've always
disagreed with it
I just want you to look at how many
decisions you get on these bare knuckle
fights you get a lot of decisions
guys it's just natural you don't want to
break your hands it hurts to hit guys in
the face with your hands you break your
hand very easily and it opens up more
cut so I don't know how many punches JDS
landed but looked like three thousand
look at verdune's face it's because they
don't have gloves on
it's just not the way it's supposed to
go down I enjoy it I like watching it
but it's very rare you get a guy like uh
Michael uh Mike Perry about to call
Michael Perry it's Michael I'm gonna
call Michael I look at Michael it's a
very rare guy like Michael Perry who
throws caution in the wind and is not
worried about breaking his hands and
that's why he's so successful
guys like JDS for Doom these other guys
they're a little more tentative a little
more calculated with their shots because
they don't want to break their hands
hurt their hands so you get this kind of
weird product I enjoy it and I think the
more it's around the more guys train and
bare knuckle it's going to get better
but right now when you watch it you can
tell they're they're reserved that
that's I think it's fair to say they're
a little more reserved because they
don't want to break their hands and
that's why the UFC is a better product
yeah still developing I remember we were
watching it was like something's kind of
missing how many decisions do we watch
we watched uh one two three so
four out of the five fights in the main
card were decisions a lot of them go to
decisions like this again you guys are
tentative they don't want to break the
freak it hurts it hurts straight up it
takes a very special sociopath like Mike
Perry to go I don't care
I think I got like Luke Rocco's like did
I just break my freaking teeth and
forget this I lost this tooth they ever
Doom's face I know they're kept they
kept talking about how his eyelid's
about to fall off yeah it didn't look
good cut up for Doom like every bit of
46 by the way and those not those look
freaking amazing his body's incredible
yeah
rightfully so he's on all them
supplements he says it's supplements
yeah yeah whatever you want to call him
yeah yeah
um I don't think the supplements you're
getting at GNC
no yeah I think I think DeSantis even
kind of popped some a long time with the
FC but something weird but uh whatever
don't be a hater I'm not gonna do that I
look up to him yeah whatever it's
physique uh all right so I don't think
you talked about on the show yet because
the the news came out oh our girl Laura
sanco yeah she killed it yeah a lot of
casuals didn't like who's this woman on
the broadcast oh she's a beast yeah you
didn't know Connor too Conor McGregor
said senko's incredible spins the chin
but nothing doing love it incredibly
refreshing addition hats off to the
whole UFC crew Stellar this evening is
Bravo only getting better what a machine
yeah she crushed it yeah and then he
gave her more opportunities too she
knows her stuff man easy on the eyes
brilliant mind
unicorn and fought too so that counts
for a lot yep
um this is kind of silly but okay so
Conor McGregor tweeted at Alex
volkanovsky ooh that's a bad idea so
this first one here on the bottom you
see this ask my bollocks that little
sausage volklanovsky is no way pound for
pound number one silly that's quick work
for me 100 actually work readable
hittable herdable I like he has this
title though we should fight at some
stage so that uh featherweight goats
will have all faced off and let there be
no debate because Alex said by the way
let's do it UFC 300 yeah
do we really think no constant cut to 45
in any reality hell no he just does to
you know be the Talk of the Town exactly
that'd be an awful fight for him and
then this is the last one from Connor
someone asked him about Conor McGregor
teases move to 85 this one you know in a
world full of fakeness and headlines
this is why Sean Strickland so massive
you're not going to see Sean Strickland
say that stuff
he's gonna be like I'll fight Connor
he's not doing this bull crap
yeah so Conor put this pic out of his
gigantic back yeah
all right and Rogan told us on campaign
he just got in usada they're Dana and
usad is making him do the six months
oh well that's legit then he hasn't yeah
they're making him do the six months
good good so you're not getting that
Michael Chandler fight for a hot second
that's the thing that sucks but yeah
okay
um this was also announced in The Green
Room Alan Belcher facing Roy Nelson for
getting their game bread bare knuckle
again Roy Nelson's gonna have success at
Bear knuckle he's a guy he has that
you know no F's given here yeah F around
and find out with Roy Nelson trust me I
left around and found out
many people have you put no gloves on
that giant dude good luck
good luck yeah
and belcher's enormous now too with like
Jack yeah I'll watch that fight
belcher's a beast
um so this was interesting I'm not sure
exactly I'm sure you probably know more
than anyone here but Tyson Fury I guess
when he was doing a press conference
with uh Francis igana he kind of said
that you're getting paid 10 known so if
he's saying you're getting paid 10 mil
for this boxing match which we thought
was more right
Tyson said that to Francis he said it in
this I'll play this right but then we
don't have to show the video case Bill I
just play the audio for you
know the UFC former UFC everyone said he
was an idiot for walking away from the
UFC and now all of a sudden he's a
genius Cindy guys vote to make 10
million dollars come on
egging their face Francis is going to
make that bug Rich pause it 10 million
guaranteed that's unclean pay-per-view
okay yeah because how would Tyson know
what the paper is I guarantee you France
gets part of the pay-per-view and gate
so close maybe not gay but definitely
pay-per-view so he's gonna make a
significant amount more than just 10.
all right yeah good but that on contract
that's what's set to make no matter what
say nobody buys pay-per-view he gets 10
mil
now a million people buy the
pay-per-view you know he's making
probably 20 25 mil
if not more
alrighty uh this was also an interesting
thing I saw on I guess Rampage teamed up
with that uh brand Jackson that makes
chains and stuff like so he has his
podcast on there nice and then Tito
Ortiz was on the podcast and he said
that the UFC and Daniel had actually
stole his idea like he created the UFC
gloves and they stole his idea and never
paid anything for it yeah
[Music]
so I did uh during podcast appearance on
the Jackson podcast where he claimed
that he played a pivotal role in
designing the UFC gloves I made those
mother efforts I gave Dana a prototype
he said he's going to make it through
and gloves wanted gloves and gloves and
gloves
why you say glass three times I don't
know if the person that printed this
gloves gloves gloves and then all of a
sudden I get cut out of the deal so what
I did was cut the thumb out I cut the
knuckles apart arm because they had the
knuckles padded I cut so it's just just
the top and I go this is how you should
make the next gloves he goes you sure I
got to I got to they were is this just a
bad translation it might be or is this
his actual I want to play the audio they
got the wrap the record tight I cut I
cut of that deal I cut of that deal they
made their own crap crap instead of
padding them mother effing gear
all right I don't I don't know
get that out that was more let's get it
out of here
you trying to ruin this podcast chin
oh God people think I talk like that I
have my own issues
okay so dog this has been making the
rounds even more recently and I looked
at how many views and likes this is
crazy it's over two two and a half
million views it's Brian wrestling
Bradley here in our studio
I mean we posted that a year ago I know
it's just making the rounds right get
with it people so this is from
philosophy fighting it says any debate
yeah I know the clip you don't play the
clip I was filming it I know I'm just
saying that this particular clip is like
it's going viral again or it's just
going viral now yeah it's Brian Bradley
Martin grappling yeah and then Brian
sweeps them
yeah Brian did very well there
uh this I thought was very weird so UFC
and Dana White I guess they filed a
lawsuit against the pillow fight
Championship because of the way the
letters and the colors are
yeah oops
hey do you have any more useless
headlines after the biggest upset of all
time
crap I can talk about that's the biggest
story can you bring up Tito T's reading
Shakespeare chin
if there was a clip hey check it out
pillow fighting is getting sued by Dana
White Dana White has nothing to do with
this you don't think that's interesting
no not anything the pillow fight yeah no
pillow fighting championship nah man all
right uh anything real man was talking
about being authentic
there's not there's not much going on
the Strickland thing was the hugest news
um all right so now I'm out of here dude
hold on so UFC 5 the game uh they
actually have a few people uh fedor's in
it now Tyson Muhammad Ali yeah that's
cool yeah the trailer's actually pretty
cool but I don't want to play it
obviously is is he on the cover he was
in the game I'm not sure if he's on the
cover oh yeah that's always a curse
that's what they said he was double
match double curse by Drake and from the
game
yeah the trick stuff it's funny but he
wins and loses fun to make fun of but um
he's not picking those fights guys
figure it out and then you did you don't
know crap about that you explain how
like they it's just the market that
stake yeah they gave him I don't know
all the money like he just post this it
won't pay you to post
I don't match people at much lower level
than Drake get paid to post stuff like
that how much you think they're paying
Drake you don't think as a ownership or
a massive payout or massive commission
when you post that stuff they're like
yeah bet on Izzy he's like okay who's he
fighting don't worry about him okay he
doesn't know I doubt he's even posting
that somebody else is doing it yeah I'm
pretty sure they're like Drake she's
probably like hey man can you guys pick
some right like it's UFC and stuff
that's why I partnered with freaking
fancy Guru we're bringing on real
experts we're gonna start when before
big pay-per-views I reached out a
fantasy Guru I was like hey you guys
they have a great track record and I was
like hey can you guys give me your pick
so I can stop doing this I don't be
known as the Drake curse here let's get
some experts in here so I partnered up
with fancy Guru for that reason alone
you guys do this you guys take all the
hate
all right here are a couple about
announcements Joaquin Buckley versus
Alex Morano that's a fun one yeah
that's a UFC fight night and then we
also have
Grant Dawson versus Bobby green they're
gonna headline
October 7th that's fun too yeah all
right and then you already knew this
you've said this the entire time but
Dana White's finally saying like yeah
he'll never say never about the Elon
Musk versus Zuckerberg from the jump
people at high levels were texting me
like do I think you're off on this man
okay
okay yeah
um
this one I thought was really jacked up
so still gone yeah that happened last
week we were here I thought we talked
about it yeah okay I didn't yeah is that
it Brad that's pretty much it
um all right that's it is yet UFC uh
fight night this is a fun one because
it's uh the Mexico card right yeah no
chase Alexa grassochenko two Matt be
interested in if uh grass can get it
done again rooting for rooting for all
the Mexicans you got Grosso she's the
last Mexican left Kevin Holland Jack uh
JDM that's a fun one uh the freaking was
he 12 years old Rosa Junior yeah yeah
he's like 14 fighting
um
Tracy Cortez one of my faves she's
getting it done too prelims I can put
Tracy on the pre-la no dude prelims
it's a good card though I'll definitely
watch it you know my girls will be
having the I'm gonna have to rock the
freaking weird Mexican hat and pinatas
and everywhere
it's a fun card though
yep and that's pretty much it dude all
right kids I will see you in Spokane
September 21st 23rd those shows are
almost sold out get your tickets right
now skank vest pretty sure sold out
September 29th we're doing a live
fighting the kid with the skank Fest
crew Friday night I think at 8pm and
then me and Brian will be doing stand up
all over that Comedy Festival skink Fest
in Vegas I'm in dubeak Iowa Dubuque
Dubuque Iowa Friday and Saturday uh
October 13th and 14th one show Friday
one show Saturday we'll add shows if we
have to but right now you have one show
Friday one show Saturday at seven
Niagara Falls the casino and then you
get those the links up for the tickets
there but that's Niagara Falls New York
and a big Casino out there that's Friday
and Saturday November 4th and 5th then
I'm in Chicago downtown Chicago real
Chicago all right and that is uh
December 8th and 9th two shows Friday
two shows Saturday but Spokane you're up
September 21st 23rd uh we should
actually do that I forgot the fan
questions yeah
or just sent these in earlier so from
Mike D uh gun to your head bow nickel
versus Strickland who would you bet the
house on bow nickel
all right Josue Angeles but to be fair
I'm bad Bo nickel against everybody it's
not no hate on Sean Strickland I'm just
that high in Beau nickel I haven't seen
anything yeah granted he's not fighting
anybody but I haven't seen anything yet
that shows otherwise that he's not the
next great white hype
uh-huh all right so Joseph angels I kind
of know what you're going to say here
but so who deserves a rematch more Izzy
or aljo
Izzy it's a there's an argument for both
but probably is he okay
that's tough because he's got beat for
25 minutes as we got clipped in the
second
both writing Champs you know but there's
a long cue
at 35.
it's tough it's tough to give either of
them a rematch
you just gotta keep the division moving
on both of them
alrighty you know that's that's good
enough for now is that good yeah
all right kids love you thanks tune in
this is the what third one live
I believe that's the third I think so
yeah this is the third all right kids uh
if you haven't yet the fight campaign
with Joe Rogan that's available on
Spotify Joe Rogan Spotify for your c293
we have uh I was actually speechless
when Sean Strickland pitched a shutout
so go watch that it's available right
now on Mr Joe Rogan Spotify
um other than that Spokane September
21st to the 23rd like subscribe do all
the stuff the kids tell you to do love
you guys be safe out there congrats to
Mr Sean Strickland insane all right kids
see you next time